what in the world just happened did we
actually just witness emu wiping an
entire island of the face of the earth
with nothing but a pen stroke this panel
of a gigantic sphere crushing the island
of lucia kingdom into the ocean not
leaving behind any trace of it is easily
one of the most ominous panels i have
ever seen in the story it's right up
there with the likes of zunisha's first
appearance or kaidos or the giant
shadows in the florian triangle but as
if this wasn't enough already ichiro
once again dropped a bombshell having
luffy reveal his true dream to the crew
and an extension to karibu who is stored
away in a barrel on the ship that i want
to say people speculated might contain
carrots but i mean who knows maybe
carrot is stored inside of karibu who
stored inside of the barrel like a
russian nesting doll kind of thing it
also looks like the crew will be
spending a lot of time with jewelry
bonnie who is one of the characters i
have been the most excited about to get
screen time and it looks like we're
about to arrive at the next island which
seems to be neither sphinx island nor
elbaf but a mysterious winter islands
once again we gotta say it's a classic
move by oda sensei going someplace none
of us could have ever anticipated and i
think it's so so awesome to finally go
back to a winter island after all this
time i mean i guess punk hazard sort of
counts but with its artificially changed
climate that was half lava and half snow
and caesar's experiments on it didn't
quite have the same energy or snowy vibe
as chopper's home country on drum island
if you know what i mean now before we
get more into the meat and potatoes of
this a quick word from today's sponsor
honkai impact third honkai impact third
is an incredibly fun and addictive to
play anime style action role playing
game for both mobile and pc in this game
you control a team of up to three
characters known as valkyries in a
real-time combat system against various
enemies and we're just in time for the
brand new version 6.0 that comes with
the new fantastic character alesia the
hairshaw of human ego three new
beautiful outfits the second phase of
the summer events plus a major update
for the main chapter and if you download
the game now and redeem this gift code
you see on screen here right now you'll
get 30 crystals 2 888 asteroids and a
herschel trial card for free but before
we get to the straw hats and all the
great and exciting stuff that's going on
with them i simply have to begin with
sabo storyline because holy usop so as
you'll remember sabo has been calling
the headquarters of the revolutionary
army on kamabaka islands to inform them
you know what has happened to him and we
do see the entire upper echelon of the
revolutionary army assembled just to
listen in what he has to report
including luffy's father monkey dragon
the four commanders ivankov heck and of
course koala and just to get it out of
the way sabo of course clarifies what
you and me already knew that he wasn't
the one that assassinated king cobra of
alabasta vivi's father what i actually
found notable here is that there is no
sign that vivi is with sabo right now
which i personally kind of would have
expected it looks like the princess is
on her own somewhere out there sabo
however quickly moves on to the next
much much more important point if we're
being honest he mentions the empty
throne inside pangaea castle and marijua
but before he's able to finish what
exactly he saw happen there in the
throne room he's apparently cut off and
we do know why because while sabo is on
the phone with the revolutionaries the
marines have been listening in sabo had
apparently been in such a hurry to share
this news that he wasn't able to get his
hands on a secure white the mushi that
can't be bugged and listened on and
either that or sabo actively wanted to
be overheard by the marines so they
would find out the truth about their
government as well that even they didn't
know that there is a true ruler of the
world that sits on the empty throne emu
the marines have successfully managed to
track sabo's location to the island of
lulucia you might remember this island
from not too long ago it was the place
where we first got introduced to the
revolutionary commanders who helped the
citizens there overthrow their cruel
king who we do see in this chapter in
prison i guess and just being a dick and
so the real banger is that the gorosei
are shocked by this reveal and actually
pity sabo why well remember when the
gorsei talked to emo about a great
cleansing and a light being extinguished
from the worlds well it turns out that
emu had decided that exactly this island
that sabo is on le lucia should be just
that light and so at least my personal
understanding of the situation right now
is that emu didn't decide to destroy
this place to keep sabo from revealing
their existence
much rather it seems more of an unlucky
coincidence that sabo is just at the
wrong place at the very wrong time and
so before sabo can actually reveal
anything the gorosei ordered the marines
communications team to cut off their
transponder snails emu is striking
through the island on a map and
immediately we see dark clouds gathering
over the islands a massive shadow
appears then a bright light accompanied
by emu's admittedly quite frightening
looking gays and a giant sphere crashes
into the island obliterating any trace
that lucia has ever existed
wow now the way this was drawn makes it
easily one of the most brutal moments in
the entire series i got actual
goosebumps reading it and i just can't
even imagine how crazy this scene will
eventually look in the anime okay so
what's in the name of usopp has happened
here what is that power that emu has
used and why did they decide to take out
this particular island in this very
extreme fashion well the first thing
that probably immediately popped out for
you as well is that what we just saw
here perfectly fits the description of
what happened to the island of god
valley an island that simply vanished
from both the maps and history a part of
the world cleansed from existence i mean
if you ever needed another reason why
love tale is a hidden island with an
unknown location now you have it if you
want a safe place to store the secrets
of the world
you better make sure that it can't be
nuked into oblivion by the main enemy
also as my editor kindly reminded me
this might actually be more evidence for
the big theory that love tale either is
below in his lobby or in the middle of
the giant whirlpool in the middle of
ender's lobby impel down in marineford
admittedly a great way to hide and
protect it from emu by it being directly
under the government's nose or maybe the
government actually knows about it being
there and just build their best
protected places around it including the
gates of justice of course there's also
the possibility that this giant gaping
hole under enes lobby might be connected
to this crazy weapon we just see falling
from the sky as well maybe it's struck
there before or it could be where it's
hidden or stored when it's not being
used in any case if you haven't checked
out those theories i strongly recommend
you do so after this video but on a
different note i found it so mean of oda
sensei to show us this little kit and
all these innocent civilians who just
regained their freedom and peace by the
way being all taken out in an instance
but of course from a storytelling
perspective it just makes this moment
just the more impactful pun intended the
only possible survivor i see here is
sabo himself who is a logia devil fruit
user and i doubt that this giant thing
was covered in haki but even then if the
entire island was destroyed and there's
only ocean left after this he might
still be in a significant amount of
trouble here though i do think that you
agree too that he will somehow pull
through and make it out of here alive
and interestingly enough this is
actually the first active evil thing
that we do see emo do so it seems like
oda sensei is really starting to set
them up as the ultimate villain of the
story oh it's getting pretty warm here
but how exactly did they do it how does
this work but panels here suggest that
emu or possibly someone else crossing
out an island on a map somehow summons
this cataclysmic power but i mean we all
know that this could just be a red
herring by oda sensei it's very much
possible that the map is simply meant to
symbolize that this island has been
wiped off the face of the earth kind of
readjusting the map and not be at all
related to this power at all but then
again maybe it is part of the power much
more important is the question
what is it and the most obvious answer
here is of course uranus it could be
that the government has somehow gotten
their hands on one of the ancient
weapons with pluton in wano and poseidon
on fishman islands uranus is still very
much unaccounted for plus the fact that
it's supposed to be a weapon connected
to the sky that can destroy the world
fits very well with what we just saw
here pretty nicely on the other hand the
ancient weapons were originally created
to oppose the world government and it's
been heavily implied that luffy needs to
collect all three of them in order to
change the world so another possibility
that i actually made a video about just
a few days ago funnily is that this is
some sort of ultimate devil fruit power
that emo wheels it could of course also
be some other sort of ancient technology
like a spaceship and i'm probably also
not the only one who remembers this
really strange moon-shaped object that
sucked in cabone badges ship after the
time skip here it's also a giant sphere
though i'm not sure it would make sense
to just smash that into the ground every
single time and then kind of retrieve it
but who knows i actually have a whole
different theory about this thing and
how it will be important the story very
very soon so make sure to subscribe if
you don't want to miss that but no
matter what exactly this thing is it's
the first time that we see some of the
true power of the world government yes
having the admirals is of course nice
but it was always clear that they would
have a much bigger ace up their sleeve
in order to control the entire world for
such a long time i'm honestly really
curious if eem's power simply lies in
controlling these powerful weapons or if
they themselves can actually fight as
well it's just amazing that just as
kaido the previously biggest calamity in
the world is out of the picture oda
sensei goes in and gives us
this love it i just want to know why
this apparently random island well it
turns out that lulucia has been
appearing in the story a number of times
as i've mentioned before it was one of
the eight countries the revolutionary
army helped to overthrow their corrupt
and cruel rulers now you might say that
this by itself might already explain why
imu decided to stomp it out but there is
more this is the same place that ace
visited during his cover story while he
was out hunting for blackbeard very
fitting that zabo is now here as well
it's here that ace befriended a little
girl similar to tama and where we get
this cover story of ace looking very
similar to nika as a silhouette on top
of that someone also linked me a very
interesting theory on reddit from over a
year ago where someone argues that
lulucia might have been the hideout for
many of the remaining level 6 prisoners
that escaped impul down during the
breakout and didn't join blackbeard the
bounty hunter jean angle tells luffy
that he tracked down all the level 6
prisoner's locations the princess of
this country who doesn't exactly get
sympathy points during this chapter
either is the one that was kidnapped on
the way to the reverie and later saved
by kobe and in an sbs oda sensei
revealed that this island used to be a
very peaceful place similarly to what we
see during aces visits before the new
king seki took over who made the people
suffer and so it would really make a lot
of sense timeline-wise that after the
mass breakout of impul down the level
six prisoners came here and helped sikhi
overthrow the previous king now whether
or not this is true i found this an
incredibly smart little theory and it
would give emo a much bigger and better
reason to destroy this place taking out
a ton of super dangerous pirates and
criminals that escaped the governments
i'm really curious how oda is going to
explain when and how emo is able to use
this weapon for example why not use it
on o'hara or on wano i mean i guess you
could argue that the marines
investigated ohara first and then found
all the stuff they found and that
destroying wanna would unleash pluton
but still it's somewhat mysterious to me
how this all is supposed to work as we
can see the crew is still trying to
catch up with and process everything
that has happened while they were busy
in one of course luffy and robin
immediately throw the idea out of the
window that sabo could have actually
killed cobra after all luffy knows his
brother and his dreams and robin has
been staying with the revolutionaries
for over two years as well absolutely
love that luffy and the rest of the crew
is immediately willing to go back to
alabaster or even marijua itself to look
for vivi as a big vv fan myself i'm
always happy whenever she's mentioned in
the story and especially when the crew
talks about her still convinced that she
will come and join up with them at some
point as a crew member
especially now i mean she might be
already on her way who knows in a really
nice throwback to early one piece zorro
is the voice of reason here telling
luffy that he needs to stay calm and
that vivi is strong and competent enough
and can look out for herself reasonable
in air quotes here because while it's
nice that zorro believes in vv i'm not
sure he makes the best argument here for
being honest i mean he reminds luffy
that he trusted in ace to solve his own
problems as well only did zorro somehow
forget how that turned out for him in
the end i mean in case you need a
reminder it's with a fist-sized hole in
the chest and luffy almost losing his
will to live
so
not exactly the best example to bring up
here i feel but i do get the gist of
what he's trying to say since no one
knows where vivi is at the moment
there's really no point in sailing
across the entire grand line looking for
her rightfully so however the rest of
the crew does tease him for it with some
fantastic nicknames including green
kaido and green big mom which were my
two favorites here now interestingly
enough luffy doesn't want to hear any
more news understandably somewhat
because there has been a lot of info
dumb recently however as a result robin
doesn't tell luffy what happened on
amazon lily and that blackbeard has now
taken kobe and i think it's reasonable
to assume that in this case even zorro
might have been willing to go and save
kobe i think it's logical that robin
didn't tell him i mean i don't think she
fully knows just how close kobe zara and
luffy were but yeah it's still
convenient that she doesn't then luffy
shares his actual dream for the very
first time with his crewmates the only
other people he told so far were ace
zabo and shanks but i want to spend too
much time on this topic honestly since
oda sensei is once again only teasing it
here but doesn't reveal anything yet the
reactions of the crew are of course
fantastic and it fits really really well
with what we've already seen from sabo
ace and shanks before i personally felt
that part of luffy's dream was what he
basically already shared with kaido
during the finale of their battle and i
know that there is a theory that luffy
simply wants to throw the world's
biggest party but i think it might still
be something even bigger than that after
all you don't really necessarily have to
become pirate king just for that i know
there's also the idea that he wants to
go to the moon again not exactly pirate
king related at first glance so we'll
just really have to wait and see what it
ends up being point is now his crew
knows and of course karibu who it turns
out has actually been on the ship with
the crew listening in and honestly my
first reaction to this was a bit of
anger i mean you have some of the best
observation hockey users on the planet
on this ship and no one notices him i
mean they did notice him on fishman
island and someone like rayleigh is able
to count the exact number of living
things on an island suddenly karibu can
hide in a barrel completely unnoticed on
open sea but then i remembered that
luffy had actually allowed him to leave
wano on his ship in udon prison so maybe
they all know exactly that he's in there
maybe frankie once again locked him up
there a second time i'm really very
curious to see what oda sensei has in
mind for karibu and who he's working for
blackbeard crocodile someone else maybe
we then skip ahead a couple of days as
the sunny enters the icy and snowy
waters around the next island
i already mentioned that i'm incredibly
excited that we're going to an
unexpected winter island decks though i
don't want to mention here that
apparently we haven't been to a single
autumn island yet in the entire story
kinda sad when you think about it but
winter is awesome too it's my favorite
season now even though the top two
contenders for the next island are off
the table with elbaf and sphynx islands
there are actually two possible winter
islands we know of in the new world that
could be where we're going next the
first one is this mysterious island that
drake went to to get kaido's attention
it's unnamed but everything to be made
out of metal it's also mentioned that
this is an island that apparently was
very important to kaido so it would be a
fitting next destination for the straw
hats after they defeated him i mean it
would surely make for some very
interesting interactions with the people
there that's for sure and in general it
kind of reminded me a lot of karakuri
islands vegapunk's birthplace and where
frankie was sent during the time skip
now on the one piece wiki it says that
this is a winter island located in the
paradise part of the grand line but
looking back through the manga i really
couldn't find anything where i said so
so maybe karakuri island is actually in
the new world that of course could make
it the arc where we finally meet
vegapunk which is really overdue and
then there's also yukiru island which
literally means snow dragon island which
is a winter island somewhere in the new
world where shanks received the news
that whitebeard had torn up his
invitation to meet now if this island is
under shanks's command that would of
course also make for a fantastic next
destination for the crew and a fantastic
lead up to elbaf where i do think luffy
and shanks will finally meet i do hope
that this is going to be maybe a 20 to
40 chapter mini arc similar to zou
before we hopefully do move on to elbaf
and of course we really need to find out
more about emu and their incredible
power i mean there are so many cool
options for an overpowered devil fruit
that they could wield if you're curious
which ones these might be well then make
sure to check out that video right here
or my discussion of the last chapter
here subscribe to the channel yes yo
subscribe
oh view you say hi
say hi